one of the first things we wanted
to keep in mind that at the end of the
day you need to build something useful
for somebody so when it first has is
figure out who is that somebody who are
you really serving and what is the job
that they're hiring you to do and
looking at it from their perspective
will often yield insights that are
hidden from the from the product owner
or entrepreneur if we're purely looking
at it from the product centric
perspective a lot of it is about being
at the right place in the right time
while you don't have control over timing
you do have control over two variables
the product in the market how you define
the product what goes into the product
and as importantly what is left out of
the product and the other variable is
the market who are you gonna sell it to
oftentimes is much more helpful to start
with the the market yes you have a set
of hypotheses about what your product is
going to deliver to whom it costs often
cost you much less to start testing your
product value proposition to a different
market segment you're just talking to
two different people you're not
investing any engineering resources to
revamp your product to build something
different that's expensive and that
limits a number of iterations you can go
through but talking to different
customers you can do that all day long
right so start with a set of hypotheses
and go on test with their customers and
iterate on a customer side as rapidly as
you can and is not just about getting
customer feedback on your product or
your prototype is actually even more
important to understand the world that
your customers live in because you often
would find that the original pain point
that you thought existed might not even
matter all that much to them but there
are adjacent pain points to that that
are much more important much more
valuable and by going after those who
could extract a lot more value and since
they are paying points adjacent to the
original pain point you wanted to tackle
you might be so lucky that your product
doesn't need to change all that much to
solve a much more valuable more
immediate and urgent pain point for the
customer
the framework consists of four
interfaces of a product user application
data and buyer the user interface is
usually the one that product designers
tend to focus on first because it drives
the whole user experience and that's
hugely important it should deserve a lot
of attention you need to really
understand what is the job that the user
is trying to do in order to design your
product accordingly in a way that fits
into their world so that's the user
interface part and most product
designers have that under very well
understood the second interface is
application interface and what I mean by
that is how do you how does your product
interact with other products that are
that exists in your end-users world or
your customers worlds what does your
user do upstream or downstream around
your product what are they doing before
they engage with the product and what
would they be doing afterwards now
understanding this is important because
one if you could better integrate
yourself with these other products that
are used by your users you have a much
higher chance of becoming embedded in
part of their standard routine to
standard workflow which means you're
more likely to become part of their
daily habits and that solves one of the
biggest problems in subscription
businesses which is churn if your users
have to keep reminding themselves to
come in and use your product chances are
you have much higher churn but if you
become part of the daily habit or part
of the standard workflow they just
follow steps one two three and step two
is your product it gets used all the
time you're gonna have much lower churn
a third benefit of thinking through your
application interface is if you have
identified upstream and downstream
applications that work well together
with your product now you could go to a
customer and offer a complete solution
not just a point product which delivers
a lot more value and you can also
leverage these application other
application vendors as your partners to
bring you into their customer base
the third interfaces is data in
interface and what I mean by
think about what input data you need
from the user or other sources in order
to do the job that users has hired you
to do what and what what is the format
that the data will be coming in what are
the channels what are the best way to
collect that data and what is the
minimum amount of data you require your
users to manually enter in order to
deliver value the more data you're
asking will use it or less likely they
will do it actually because you're
increasing the cost of adopting your
product but if you could minimize the
manual data input required of your user
and try to automate the the process of
delivering value as much as possible and
sometimes are inferring conclusions or
making predictions based on other data
sets that you can automatically ingest
into your product chances are you'll be
able to deliver a high level value with
a lower cognitive cost to your user so
that's the input side on the output side
you need to think about how the data is
going to be consumed if the data you
generate is a report for example that is
read by human being you want to make
sure the visualizations are crisp and
engaging if on the other hand get the
data that you generate are going to be
consumed by machines or other products
downstream you might need to think about
how best should I format the data and
through what channels should I be
delivering the data so that it I
maximize the likelihood of the data
being consumed and made valuable by a
downstream product and in the last
interface buyer interface refers to the
interface between the product and the
buyer which may not be the end user and
this is often times the interface that
is most this is this is the interface
that is most often neglected by product
designers because to design a product
that is easily consumed by a buy or
purchase by a buyer requires deep
understanding of how your buyer makes
purchasing decisions and this set of
activities often viewed as something
owned by sales or marketing
not by product and engineering but
without understanding how a buyer
discovers and purchases your product you
miss out on the opportunity of
optimizing the design of your product to
be to be purchased as easily as possible
I'll give you an example if a an
organization requires a certain trial
period for a product before they would
decide to buy you would want to design
your product in such a way that the
trial period could be self served by the
customer or prospect a potential
customer without requiring a lot of
pre-sales resources on your part
otherwise it would be much more costly
for you to qualify a lead and scale your
revenue so this is a example of how
understanding the buying process has
impact on your product design decisions
what's the most common trap that
entrepreneurs fall into is if you're
getting some level of traction you are
seeing some level of growth but it's
just not explosive and that's a hard
thumb to be in because it's hard to give
up you have customers you're seeing
growth is just not explosive growth but
if you're not driving explosive growth
then it's hard to become a dominant
player in your industry so that's
probably the most difficult zone to be
in because you have always been drawn to
staying with what is somewhat working in
a market that what the odds winner needs
to do in that case is to look for ways
to get to that perfect product market
fit so that your revenue will start
picking up exponentially it could be by
pricing a product definitely positioning
differently or going after an adjacent
market segment without changing a
product all that much